100 tage was man in denen alles machen
könnte einen sehr langen urlaub 32 mal
alle folgen game of thrones schauen am
stück oder einfach 5142 folgen heute
journal kopien also wenn ihr die augen
dann auch offen halten können
logischerweise für politikerinnen und
politiker einer neuen regierung sind die
ersten 100 tage normalerweise eine art
schonzeit erst danach werden sie
bewertet aber das ist gerade schon
normal sicherlich nicht die ersten 100
tage im amt von olaf scholz mit
diskussionen um omikron impfpflicht und
krieg in europa was passiert ist und vor
allem wie die menschen in deutschland
seine arbeit bewerten darum geht es
jetzt
[Musik]
bevor wir über olaf scholz und seine
ersten 100 tage als bundeskanzler
sprechen müssen wir erst einmal die zahl
klären 100 ist ja an sich eine schöne
zahl sieht nicht nur schick aus die
mathematiker kommen ganz in schwärmen
schließlich ist 100 die vollendete form
der zweiten potenz von 10 und auch die
summe der ersten neuen primzahlen danach
aber bitte nicht jetzt habe ich übrigens
alles gelesen ich hatte keine ahnung
aber warum sind es jetzt eigentlich 100
tage für die neue regierung nicht 50
oder 250 die 100 tage schonfrist werden
wie eine findungsphase angesehen danach
ziehen vor allem die medien aber auch
die opposition bilanz ganz ursprünglich
geht diese zeitspanne wohl am ehesten
auf us präsidenten franklin roosevelt
zurück der habe sich 1933 zeit erbeten
bis seine neuen und umfangreichen
wirtschaftsreformen des new deal greifen
sollten und für diese zeitspanne gibt es
kein gesetz oder irgendeine regel es ist
quasi einfach ein willkürlich gesetzte
zeitpunkt allerdings muss man sagen so
eine richtige schonzeit hatte olaf
scholz gar nicht zu viele
herausforderungen warteten da auf ihn
werfen deshalb mal kurz einen blick
zurück auf die anfangszeit unseres
bundeskanzlers die jetzt immerhin schon
ungefähr drei monate her ist wie
bewertet ihr übrigens olaf scholz raps
gerne in die kommentare ich bin sehr
gespannt was er darüber denkt da können
wir ein kleines bisschen diskutieren am
8 dezember 2021 übernimmt olaf scholz
die amtsgeschäfte als bundeskanzler nach
5860 tagen im amt von angela merkel und
was dachten die deutschen damals schauen
wir mal aus politbarometer die umfragen
der forschungsgruppe wahlen für das zdf
am 10 dezember wird veröffentlicht 77
der befragten glauben dass olaf scholz
seine sache als bundeskanzler er gut
machen wird und bei der umfrage zu den
beliebtesten politikern landet er im
ranking auf platz zwei mit einem
durchschnittswert von 2,1 auf einer
bewertungsskala von +5 bis -5 die genau
das ranking zustande kommt das haben wir
euch schon mal in einem eigenen video
erklärt das findet ihr wenn ihr oben
auch das klingt also kann man sagen gar
kein so schlechter start wenn auch noch
im schatten von angela merkel aber
gerade im amt stehen in der politik
direkt wichtige entscheidungen für olaf
scholz an eine der zentralsten ist wie
macht man weiter in der korona pandemie
und vor allem auch mit der neuen virus
variante omikron es geht um alte und
neue maßnahmen das
infektionsschutzgesetz und natürlich die
impfpflicht für gesundheitseinrichtungen
sowie die dann etwas später diskutierte
allgemeine impfpflicht das ist noch mal
ein ganz anderes thema und man muss
sagen immer noch nicht ganz
abgeschlossen kriegte er sicherlich auch
mit eine woche nach der ernennung als
bundeskanzler folgt die erste
regierungserklärung von olaf scholz am
15 dezember 2021 die reaktionen darauf
die sind gemischt die zuhörenden
scheinen wenig gefesselt ein
rundfunksender spricht von einem
bestseller als hörbuch zum einschlafen
scholz erklärt darin eineinhalb stunden
eigentlich vor allem noch mal was schon
im koalitionsvertrag steht dann wird es
anscheinend stiller und bundeskanzler
olaf scholz einige haben ihn ja schon
als nur sichtbar oder abgetaucht
bezeichnet und seine umfragewerte die
sinken als olaf scholz in die usa reist
anfang februar da wird im netz vor allem
über seinen xxl pullover beim
journalisten termin im flieger
diskutierte vielleicht auch mitbekommen
so ein schlabberpulli in grau dabei geht
es schon damals mit us präsident joe
biden um das russische säbelrasseln und
an der ukrainischen grenze mitte februar
sind nur noch 56 prozent der befragten
beim politbarometer der meinung dass
olaf scholz seine sache gut machen würde
gut zwei drittel sind sogar der meinung
dass es scholz an führungsstärke fehlen
würde in der bewertung des politiker
ranking rutschte er von note 2,1 auf 1,3
ab am 15 februar sitzt oder scholz dann
aber inzwischen berühmt gewordenen
langen tisch von wladimir putin dann
überschlagen sich die ereignisse die
situation in der ukraine spitzt sich zu
am 24 februar greift die russische armee
die ukraine an und das ist klar das wird
auch eine große herausforderung für olaf
scholz und an seinem krisenmanagement
wird er gemessen werden drei tage später
am 27
februar hält der bundeskanzler eine
regierungserklärung im bundestag
wir werden von nun an jahr für jahr mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts und unsere
verteidigung um das tier einer der
zentralen punkte in dieser
regierungserklärung die rüstungsausgaben
werden erhöht eine politische kehrtwende
oder eine zeitenwende wie er es nennt
nicht nur von olaf scholz sondern auch
der gesamten bisherigen deutschen
sicherheitspolitik
und wie kommt das an dazu muss man sagen
die situation rund um den ukraine krieg
ist sehr dynamisch deshalb wurde
entschieden dass das politbarometer bei
den umfrageergebnissen die unmittelbar
vor dem einmarsch russlands erhoben
wurden nicht veröffentlicht wird weil
die lage nicht mehr adäquat abgebildet
werden kann scholz telefoniert mit putin
und versucht immer wieder mit anderen
politikern zu vermitteln zu den
aktuellen ereignissen haben euch die
kollegen der zdf heute auch eine
playlist rund um den russland ukraine
krieg zusammengestellt findet ihr wie
alles andere auch oben auf dem i und
unten in der infobox die aktuellsten
zahlen des politbarometers am 11 märz
2022 liegt olaf scholz mit seiner
bewertung bei 1,9 im februar war seine
beliebtheit ja wie gesagt noch bei 1,3
punkten aber wie sind die bewertungen
einzuordnen denken die deutschen dass er
seine sache gut macht dazu andrea wolf
von der forschungsgruppe wahlen also
aktuell hat er sehr viel zustimmung und
es gibt die große zufriedenheit mit
seiner arbeit mit der arbeit der
bundesregierung
das heißt diese delle die wir gesehen
haben so anfang februar dies weg und es
liegt natürlich an der ukraine krise an
dem krieg dort jetzt die frage ist kann
man daraus ein muster erkennen oder
einen trend kneipe kampf oder in
krisenzeiten immer besser ab das heißt
ja auch immer in krisenzeiten sind
regierungszeiten und dies trifft jetzt
auch wieder zu
die bevölkerung sammelt sich dann ein
stück weit hinter der regierung man
erwartet von der regierung dann dass die
führung übernimmt das die verantwortung
übernimmt und das ist ja jetzt auch
geglückt und es zeigt sich jetzt eben
auch in den werten die zufriedenheit ist
wieder deutlich hoch gegangen auch die
persönlichkeitswerte von jobs sind
deutlich hoch gegangen und deshalb bis
jetzt eine zustand wo man sagen kann ja
also erwirkt
erfährt große reputation und diese man
setzt auch viel vertrauen gegeben ganz
wichtig ist die zahlen sind natürlich
immer stand jetzt zur aufzeichnung
dieses videos mitte märz ganz aktuelle
zahlen findet ihr immer auf der website
der forschungsgruppe wahlen oder im
internet beim zdf politbarometer den
link unten in der infobox 100 tage
bundeskanzler olaf scholz kein einfacher
start für den neuen kanzler der krieg
hat zudem vieles verändert der oft
pragmatische und leise kanzler von dem
viele schon behauptet haben dass er
abgetaucht sei steht jetzt wieder voll
im fokus und mit ihnen natürlich auch
das krisen-management die politischen
und vor allem sicherheitspolitischen
folgen und auch die humanitären und
wirtschaftlichen folgen des krieges auch
sie werden ein großes thema sein in der
kommenden zeit und wie wird man olaf
scholz dann bewerten wenn die sanktionen
gegen russland auch in deutschland
spürbarer werden mit ihren folgen ich
bin kein fan von floskeln aber momentan
ist es einfach so dass vieles so
unvorhersehbar ist dass man gar nicht
weiß was die zukunft bringen wird
verlassen könnt ihr euch nur darauf dass
es auch in zukunft das politbarometer
geben wird das auskunft gibt wie sich
das entwickelt und auch das
politbarometer to go wird es weiterhin
die auf dem kanal geben hier neben mir
findet ihr noch mal das angesprochene
video hinter den kulissen des politiker
rankings und darunter noch ein video von
einem kanal in dem es um die aktuelle
situation
und wie gesagt ich bin sehr gespannt auf
eure bewertung zur arbeit von olaf
scholz als bundeskanzler in den ersten
100 tagen schreibt das gerne unten in
den kommentaren
danke dafür danke fürs zuschauen und bis
zum nächsten mal